un reclamo de libertad frente a la
asamblea legislativa madres y familiares
de quienes fueron detenidos durante el
régimen de excepción se pronunciaron en
contra de la eventual ampliación de la
medida los nombres de los detenidos
presidía la protesta de exijo al al
gobierno
que libere a estas gentes hombres y
mujeres que están detenidos
inocentemente en el corazón en la mano
mi hijo nunca
anduvo delinquiendo yo le pido a dios y
a este gobierno le dé libertad al hombre
y mujer inocente las autoridades se
resguardaron el área adjunta de la
asamblea ante la llegada de los
manifestantes y es que el gabinete de
seguridad pedirá la próxima semana al
congreso que apruebe una nueva
ampliación del régimen de excepción los
reclamos llegaron de disímiles maneras
incluso exigiendo el derecho a ser
atendidos a golpe de megáfono
en el estado de excepción en el salvador
se encuentra vigente de este finales de
marzo en el se suspenden las garantías
constitucionales para darle poderes
especiales al ejecutivo organizaciones
humanitarias de diversas partes del
mundo han recopilado al menos tres mil
denuncias por violaciones a los derechos
humanos casi 50.000 personas han sido
detenidas desde el inicio de la
disposición uno de los pocos datos que
se conocen oficialmente